[MUSIC PLAYING]
So I'm John.
I'm the engineering tech lead
for the Player Analytics team.
And to repeat some of what
Ben was saying earlier
in our keynote, the
Player Analytics package
will let you do three things.
It will let you manage your
business against daily revenue
targets, understand when and
where players are spending,
getting stuck, and
churning in your game,
and then meet your daily needs.
So you get access
to this pretty much
for free by integrating
with Google Play game
services, which you might
have been doing before
for things like
achievements, Quests,
saved games, things like that.
But we're going to look
at Events right now.
Events were the
backbone for Quests
and Events allow
us to monitor what
players are doing in your game.
We're going to leverage that
so we can monitor things
like how they're
doing, things like
spending money in your game,
or buying premium currency.
So let's look at how that works.
So you go to the
console and then
you're going to select one of
the Events that you've created.
And you can select
those Events and you
can set them to be either
premium currency sources
or premium currency syncs.
And then after you annotate
the Events in the console,
you go to your code.
And in your code, just like
what you did with Events before,
you'll tell us, with
these RPC calls,
when players are actually
getting the premium currency
or spending a premium currency.
This will allow us to analyze
how premium currencies exist
in your game and
to hopefully let
you understand that yourself.
But premium currency
analysis is really
just one of the few things
that the Player Analytics
package does for you overall.
So let's look at
some other examples
of how we can use this.
So here we have
Darlene the developer.
And Darlene is convinced that
the world needs another game
about killing zombies
and farming for corn.
In fact, she wants
to make a game
in which you do both of these
things at the same time.
So she programs up her game
and then she launches it.
And she finds just
after her launch
that lots and lots
of people are playing
her new game, Zombie Farmer.
And this is
fantastic, of course,
because some of these people
are actually paying her money.
But she does an
iterate on her game
and what she finds 30
days after she launches
is that not so many people
are playing her game.
Well, this kind of
freaks her out of course.
And naturally,
she's going to have
a lot of questions like,
do people like corn
farming as much as she does?
Do they like killing
zombies more?
Should she add more zombies?
Less zombies?
Is this game too
hard or too easy?
These are all great questions
but without any analytics,
you can't answer them.
So the way that we try to
answer these questions for her
is we build detailed
time series of what's
going on with every single user
that is connected to Google
Play game services in her game.
We create this time series.
In these time series,
we put everything
that we know about the players.
So here's another
example of a time series
but the things that go in this
time series are things like all
of the achievements
that they've earned,
all of the Events
that they've unlocked,
every spend that they do,
whenever they hit retention,
whenever they abandon the game.
Pretty much everything
we know about the players
we put into these time series.
Once we have these
time series-- and we
could have millions of
times series of course
for all the players
that are playing games--
we aggregate information about
these time series together.
Spend statistics,
retention statistics,
progression statistics.
In fact, let's look a little bit
more at progression statistics.
What we do right here is
we're defining progressions
as the number of
achievements that someone
has unlocked during your game.
And what Darlene finds
is that once people
get to Level Six of unlocking
achievements, only 50% of them
get to Level Seven.
So Darlene decides
that she wants
to make a new
version of her game
in which she makes
Level Seven easier.
After she does that,
she launches that
and she comes back
to our retention
widget in which we've broken
down retention by cohort.
And she finds that
people that started
playing her game before only had
20% percent two-day retention.
And maybe afterwards
they have 50% retention.
So this right here is an example
of the business drivers page
that we have.
And this is really
powerful because it
allows Darlene to compare
how her game is doing
to other games in her same genre
making roughly the same amount
of money as hers.
All the boxes that
we have here in green
in this made-up example indicate
that her retention statistics
are actually just fine
compared to other games.
But her spend statistics,
in particular her ARPU,
is much lower.
So she puts on the ARPU
button and she gets a drill
down piece of
information for ARPU.
So here on the top we
have a graph that shows,
broken down by day over the
last 28 days, what her ARPU was.
But in addition to ARPU,
we also have ARPPU,
we have conversion rate.
We have basically all
of the spend statistics
that we could cram into a graph.
The general idea that's
coming out from this
is that once she has
launched her game,
she needs to continue
iterating on it
and we provide the
analytics package that
allows us to do that so she can
make her game better and better
and get more and more
players in her game.
The main thing to
take away from this
is that Player Analytics
allows you to do three things.
And I think this is probably
the sixth time you've heard
us say something like this.
But it allows you to manage your
business against daily revenue
targets, understand
when and where players
are getting stuck or
churning in your game,
and quickly identify the
business metrics that are
in most need of your attention.
We'll be at the Code Labs today.
Please feel free to drop in.
We can talk about how to
get this into your game.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]